pleurant à cause de la détérioration de
la situation sécuritaire à Belfast, votre
régiment est maintenant déployé là-bas
en urgence. Je ne veux pas que vous
vous inquiétiez pour moi.
Communauté catholique, nous devons
aller là-bas et rassurer les gens pour que vous les
protégiez, nous devons les regarder dans les
yeux et leur dire
[ __ ] d'officier supérieur debout droit
Je ne suis pas là pour effacer vos [ __ ] d'
erreurs
est-il mort soldat hé votre  la morsure de balle
ne se souciait pas de toi tu es juste un
morceau de viande eux qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
alors
on va le tuer tout le monde
cherche ce garçon tu me dois une femme j'ai besoin d'une
faveur
nous commercial alors où est la [ __ ] d'
histoire  Digne me dire que c'est un message que
ce choix vous fera correspondre s'ils ont
obtenu